all right so where do the saints go from
here at quarterback now
i don't think it's a coincidence
that
within an hour right maybe a half hour
after drew brees posting his farewell
video
we get word of this taysom hill
restructuring huge that's right
huge gigantic didn't you hear they're
paying taysom hill
four years 140 million dollars there's
just one caveat it's all fake other than
that it is one hell of a contract the
details are great as shefty said oh by
the way it's all fake it's all phony
they could have picked any number they
wanted they could have grabbed it out of
the air or pulled it out of any other
orifice and i think they did
the numbers are phony the whole idea was
to add four years to the current one
year more and more teams are doing this
where you're putting these voidable fake
years on the back end so you can spread
out salary cap dollars even more so you
got a guy who's under contract for one
more year
you add four avoidable years you make it
140 million on the four years
coincidentally or not 35 million a year
that's what russell wilson makes those
numbers are never going to be paid it's
just to take the money that taysom hill
is going to make this year spread it out
create 7.75 million in cap space but the
key is this yeah
they're paying him all the money now
they're gonna
so
he's the he's on the team i'm not saying
he's the guy he's on the team right
it makes it far less likely russell
wilson's coming to town and far less
likely they would do a trade of taysom
hill
as part of a russell wilson package
because when you when you pay that money
out when you convert it to a guarantee
you you set yourself up for a major cap
charge if you would trade him so
regardless of whether or not he's the
starter
his his name on the depth chart has gone
from pencil to pen
hill is on there the question is who
else is going to be on there well here
and here's the here's the thing i want
to ask you first before we even dive
into that so
next year right just so i got this right
it is a team option
basically no
no
it all voids it all voids all voids
all voids the the only question is this
right and as of last night this was
unresolved there's there's a little
devil lurking in the details as to when
the years void the agents try to avoid
the years after the franchise tag
deadline that's what happened with dak
prescott's deal
the team would probably prefer to avoid
it before the franchise tag deadline so
they'd still have the option to use the
tag but those four years are going to go
away at some point before the start of
the 2022 league year and he'll become a
free agent a year from today whatever
today specifically is when the free
agency period starts in 2022. so it's a
one-year deal now they could always
extend it yeah right but a truly
extended not phony extended right but
but this was all about reducing cap
space the tooth i said i asked somebody
well let's taste some he'll get out of
this two things he gets all of his money
fully guaranteed not that there was any
doubt and he creates cap space that
allows the saints to have a better team
around him right exactly right yeah but
but you also look at and say he creates
cap space that they can give to jameis
winston who'll come in and compete with
him too well yeah maybe maybe there's no
doubt about that but i still think you
know when the position takes him hills
in right now too
this this is the best option he's got
and you know for the sake of this
conversation and we're talking about the
saints and what goes on there i mean i
would be shocked if taysom hills not the
starting quarterback or at least the
starting quarterback going into training
camp and going to get every opportunity
to be that guy
it's been too many years now
what are we going into here year four
of you know gushiness about taste some
hill and what he can maybe do with this
offense i mean this is sean i mean i
think this is the reason maybe we we
felt like sean payton was pushing drew
brees out the door a little bit
we we have heard that this is his toy
this is his new little experiment on
this side of the ball let alone taysom
hill does have an interesting skill set
i mean it's legit his arm is really
powerful and explosive you know his
ability to run is is special it's up
there with anybody in the nfl when it
just comes to tucking the ball and
running so i would think he is the guy
there's no doubt but you're right
there's gonna be somebody else to go
along with it whether that's a jameis
winston or
uh i don't know a tie rod taylor
somebody else that at least is a
somewhat of a proven commodity and
played enough football in the nfl
because the saints even though they've
had to let go of a lot of players i
think we still look at them and go
they're still they're not going to fall
off earth here we've seen them play
without drew brees the last two years
they've been damn good without them so
uh but but they got some work to do here
and i expect taysom hill to still be the
guy i mean don't you and then maybe
we'll see who comes in as a backup
yeah absolutely and it's an attractive
spot for a backup it was attractive in
the recent years when it was teddy
bridgewater who was 5-0 as the starter
in 2019 it was attractive for jameis
winston last year and now with brees
gone and hill's got that bruising style
he turns 31 on august 23. now i know 31
is the new 21 as far as quarterbacks go
but when you're talking about a guy who
likes to rumble bumble and stumble with
the football and really is that bull in
the china shop when he takes off with
the ball and people get out of his way
you still have the chance of injury
remember he tweaked his knee last year
at some point and missed at least one
game if i recall correctly and there's a
chance i don't but that backup spot very
valuable there's there's there's uh
reason to believe you're going to get a
chance to play and and sean payton may
want to try you out from time to time he
likes to show off what he can do with
his quarterbacks it was james winston
not taysom hill that threw that pass in
the playoff game against the
who was it against buccaneers
the homage to what the bears did the
prior week against the saints right the
guy dropped the pass or it would have
worked perfectly it worked perfectly but
for the fact that the guy dropped the
pass
they didn't drop the pass in the saints
game and it was winston that threw it
i'm told that they still want winston
chris i would think so but but they're
low balling
they're lowballing right and and they're
not offering him i'm told much more than
what they paid him last year the
question is is someone else going to
come along with enough
of a financial package that squeezes the
saints to give more or will the saints
just say
go ahead hey viacom dios and and enjoy
your new your new spot uh you know
because i think there's there's still an
attraction to winston another year in
new orleans just like teddy bridgewater
did and look at where it led three-year
66 million dollar contract yeah the
panthers had done with him after a year
but he still got paid they did he still
got paid and the difference is winston's
made winston's made number one overall
pick money right he got the 20 million a
couple of years ago in his option year
so i don't know how motivated he is by
chasing
a payday
but
um you know unless unless there's a
clear path to a starting job somewhere
else i don't know why he wouldn't stay
put like
like
please yeah they're lowballing him and
what do you make last year mike five
million was it like just north of that i
don't even think it made that it was low
based and it was some incentives yeah
when you total it all up i think it was
under five yeah okay okay i know i can't
remember off the top of my head either
but i mean i understand them low balling
low balling him i i get that they know
the situation sean payton knows his own
damn worth too is what he is as an
offensive coach and yeah they're going
to look at it like to what you said mike
and they're going to go i mean i got the
teams in front of me right now who's
going to bring jameis winston as a
starter who
i mean maybe i mean seattle i don't i
mean if they traded russell wilson i
don't i don't know but i just can't
imagine anybody else out there is going
to bring him in as a starter so then you
go to that next conversation okay jameis
you're not a starter now where do you
want to be a backup oh okay yeah you you
really you want to go to some of these
other teams and be a backup and you know
being a crappy offense or not have a
great support system and do that you
know that that to me yeah you're rolling
the dice i i think they know jameis
winston is chomping at the bit to want
to be a starting quarterback again sean
payton's smart enough to realize his
team's the best way to go for him to get
to that route and i i mean i would be
shocked you know i would be shocked for
james winston just a guy who's sitting
here watching his career like i think
we're both in agreement you go back
there there's no doubt you've laid out
all the reasons taste some hill the way
he plays everything like that i mean
yeah you're you're one play away from
him lowering the shoulder against some
linebacker and you're playing four or
five weeks and you play good you could
be a starter that next season so i i
expect jameis to come back
no matter what the price is
the bears would be a potential option
depending upon what they ultimately
choose residue
last we heard 10 days ago they were
going to try to get russell wilson if
you go son jameis winston that probably
makes it a little more difficult and i
think winston's going to want to know
what you know and and the contract is
going to speak to what you think of the
guy right how much you're offering him
on the way in tells you whether he's
pegged
below the starting spot or whether
you're handing him the keys and there's
been nothing to suggest the bears plan
to go after jameis winston and and you
know for the saints you look at the the
free agent options that are out there
alex smith is a backup uh i i don't i
who knows i'm just going to rattle off
the names you tell me if any of them i i
i
has potential backups to take some hill
right alex smith jacoby brissette
mitchell trubisky ryan fitzpatrick tyrod
taylor a guy you mentioned aj mccarron
andy dalton colt mccoy
rg3 and then you get down to the matt
barkley's nate sutfelds ryan griffin joe
flocco's of the world i look
i
i it's it's
yeah maybe tyrod taylor andy dalton
fitzpatrick and tyrod taylor are the
three guys i would say out of that list
like i don't
i don't know i just don't i can't
imagine mitchell trubisky he's not quite
the polish polish passer they'd maybe be
scared of him jacoby brissette seems
like he's maybe fit for a different
offense altogether
i don't know those are the three names
that that ring out to me that say like
hey here's a backup
but if we get if these if we get hurt or
our starter gets hurt these guys are
plenty good with my offense to make
things work and that's where i think
andy that's where i think jameis wins is
going gonna have to look at that list
too and go
wait there there there's some decent
backups here i'm not exactly the crown
jewel of free agency and like a team
like the bears they'd be crazy to take
jameis winston they'd both be crazy to
take each other i mean the bears if that
goes wrong the slightest bit everybody's
gonna go you brought jameis winston the
turnover king here these guys can't
evaluate quarterbacks what the hell are
they doing we gotta fire them you know
and i would also go to james winston and
go what the hell is that offense showing
you that you want to go there and play
on that anyways
i gotta see it to believe it first to
know that offense is gonna work so i
would say both of them stay away from
each other and jameis go back to new
orleans
just remember this though jameis winston
to get back to where we started 5 000
yard passers they're all hall of famers
are on their way to the hall of fame
because mahomes has it too and
roethlisberger has it and he'll get
there stafford one name
matthew well
got some work to do in l.a but but at
least the door is open for him right
there's jameis winston eighth all time
5109
only four guys have thrown for more
yards in a single season than winston
and they're peyton manning drew brees
tom brady and ben roethlisberger so
there is good there yeah there is
potential there
and i think his best potential is going
to be to stay
in new orleans
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports